there are only three sharks that
regularly attack humans the massive
great white the Swift sleek tiger and
the often ignored but dangerous bull
shark
my kite house from Florida International
University studies the bull probably get
the name bull shutters they're so big
and stocky I kind of think of it more as
the pitbull of the scenes it's a fitting
description bull sharks can be tenacious
and aggressive they're not as large as
the great white but female bulls can
grow to over 11 feet and weigh up to 500
pounds they also have one very special
characteristic one of the most amazing
things about these bull sharks is that
they go from marine to freshwater with
no problems
Bulls have been found thousands of miles
upstream in both the Mississippi and
Amazon rivers they also are believed to
hunt in the same shallow coastal waters
where unsuspecting each goers frolic in
the summer
there are also opportunistic hunters
they'll eat just about anything Mike
wants to know more about bull sharks and
their feeding habits so he's attached
critter cams to the Sharks
underwater cameras equipped with
satellite tags once ready there's a
shark nice boy that's exactly what we
need
the Crittercam reveals at least one
other bull in the region which raises
the intriguing possibility that these
sharks may be interacting satellite data
also confirmed that the Bulls stay put
never venturing far from where the team
caught them that's more proof that these
animals may be an important part of the
coastal environment but in regards to
sharks and us it showed that Bulls do
like to hunt and hang out in the same
shallow waters we flock to every summer
ultimately though it does us all good to
remember that you are more likely to get
struck by lightning than bit by a shark